please welcome jonathan
[Applause]
thank you so much for having me thank
you everybody here it's so exciting to
be here
i have wanted to meet you for so long i
really have i've been such a fan of
yours for years and years and years who
is the real jonathan groff who are you
i think it might be kristoff actually i
think it might be
i think it might be christopher tell me
why
i love
giving hugs
i like being in nature uh-huh i can be a
little bit of a loner okay
i'm a very loyal
great as a friend
and i think he's really cute
now when you're doing like the matrix
which i watched last night
you're once again this ice king
this anomaly the i can't get in but i
want in there's a
sexiness a coldness
how do you attack something like that
the matrix felt like the total
reverse of who i am in real life the
character with all the fighting and the
kung fu and the
sort of brutalistic kind of energy
that comes out of that character i was
shocked when i was cast and i felt like
oh wow this is really something outside
of myself lana wachowski the incredible
director of the matrix i'm such a fan of
hers
so i had faith in her and i just jumped
and went into it but showing up on that
first day of fight training and keanu
reeves
is in his jujitsu outfit oh my god
sweating fighting
like doing all that yeah super hot like
i know about it i knew him next level i
made a film with him when i was 11 years
old so i feel like it's just
inappropriate to have those feelings
about him but
not at all not at all when you were a
kid you used to play dress-up and you
had a rich fantasy look at you there
peter pan is that you as peter pan
you're so cute that was peter pan
oh
i'm sorry what apparatus is that i know
that was our float the halloween parade
floats in my hometown in strasbourg pa
uh when i was i think six years old i
was peter pan and my brother was captain
hook and someone was just like oh i
happen to have one of these things
laying around
let's
throw it
[Applause]
okay the holidays are right around the
corner and i was wondering if i could
ask you a final five of some oriented
questions
ladies and gentlemen the final five
holiday edition
my crew
you're the birds
okay holiday memory that sticks out for
you when my brother
went into the garage
and my mom had had all of the christmas
presents in her van
and he had left something in the van and
he went to go get it
and he saw the presents and my mom
freaked out and said you ruined
christmas
you saw all the presents he had to
convince her he didn't really see them
and it was we we worked our way through
it but it was it was jarring best gift
ever given to you my mom again she gave
me i'm i'm an avid bike rider and she
gave me this like denim levi's
biking jacket that i still wear that
i've had for years oh
i love that okay best gift you ever gave
last year it was a random gift
my i have a six-year-old niece avelina
and a four-year-old niece estelle
was this cat
that would like went it was like meow
and it moved like a robot and there was
this
leash attached to it it was sort of i
thought this is a silly
stupid gift but i'll get it for them if
they like cats it was the gift they
played with the whole christmas
favorite holiday decoration this one's
easy actually my my mom
decorates an epic tree every year 30
years ago when i was six
i made you know when you with markers
you draw
like colored lights but they're with
paper and markers uh-huh and you string
them like they're real lights uh-huh she
has them still and still puts them on
the tree every year favorite holiday
tradition also an easy one this is the
gingerbread decorating competition that
we have every year
and uh does your mom sponsor it
she makes the gingerbread from scratch
she does
and she shapes the cookies and then and
then we all decorate and this is the
this is the big challenge i've won the
last three years i had that yeah
well wow so cool thank you so much i
i definitely
wanted to meet you because i love you
for so many reasons and one of the
things i didn't expect to come out of
this piece was now how much i'm in love
with your mom
please wish her
a very happy christmas for me because
um i'm trying to be like her your mom is
amazing and so are you and i love you so
much in this matrix
resurrections which comes out december
22nd and it'll be in theaters and hbo
max and thank you jonathan croft thank
you so much
[Music]